[Music]
after two hours ago right here at Onslow
City Hall the 2022 Nobel Peace Prize was
received by Jan rachinski from Memorial
Alexandra Matt dechuk from Ukraine
Center for civil liberties and Natalia
pinchuk the wife of jail Belarusian
human rights activist Alexis
[Applause]
[Music]
the
doctor in terms of
another International this Noble this
prizes recognition of the efforts of the
whole Ukrainian Nation who bravely
struggled for freedom and for our
Democratic choice
and this is a huge responsibility
because this is a Nobel Peace Prize
during the war and during the very
bloody war before for decades the voice
of Human Rights Defenders from our
region wasn't heard so it's provide us a
unique opportunity
[Music]
when we started our documentation in
2014 we focused on the practice of legal
abduction torture sexual violence and
killing civilians because Russia used
tactics a terror against people on the
occupied territories in order to save
their control
and we sent numerous reports to U.N to
OAC Council of Europe and nothing
stopped this horror still continue and
after large-scale Invasion we faced with
unprecedential level of human faith
[Music]
[Applause]